hi everyone alex gin here so in today's
video i'm gonna be talking about what an
isolation is
and not the quarantine kind make sure
you stick around to the end of the video
because i'll also be talking about the
martial applications of these movements
okay so let's get into it
so i'll be explaining how an isolation
works with a staff club
and also a sword but to begin with i'm
going to explain the principles with
this ball and chain
i don't recommend you do this if you if
you haven't experienced this type of
thing before
as it's quite heavy so i suggest using
something like a
tennis ball and a sock if you want to
try this movement out so if i start off
this movement
by rotating around my wrist you can see
here
this is the pivot point as it as the
ball goes round
it's just all rotating around this one
point
however if i start to move my hand out
you can see the rotation point has now
changed and it's actually
in the middle of the chain
and that's because i'm pulling
at an opposite force as the ball is
dropping
round so as the ball travels round
i'm giving it that little bit of a pull
and obviously this needs to change
depending on where the ball is obviously
at the top it becomes lighter
and then as it drops down gravity starts
to
pull it down further and then i've got
to give it that pull
in that counter direction so then you
start to get a movement where you're
following the ball round
we can actually then manipulate it much
easier
as we've got more control over the
object
so as it's spinning around as i can feel
the weight
so i'm pulling in the the equal amount
on the off in the opposite direction
i can then start to switch it so i start
to change the direction
in whichever way i want
and that's because i've got that control
where i'm just following the motion
wherever the ball goes i can then
go off on a tangent so if you think of
the circle is like this i can then shoot
off
whichever tangent i want so the most
obvious use of this movement is if you
applied it to something like a rope dart
or meteor where when it's spinning
around you're letting the movement
fire off into whichever direction you
want
now obviously this is just on a short
chain but the same would apply if it was
on a longer chain
using those same principles but how does
it also apply to the staffing sword
so if we take the staff one way to look
at it is to isolate
around a certain point for example where
my elbow is and rotate
around that one point and then you get
some effect that looks like this
now that is the same movement if we did
it with the club
i can isolate around my elbow
and get that same effect with the club
same as with the staff so if i for
example take a figure eight motion
rather than rotating around my wrist
like i did with the
ball and chain i could pick another
point and move around that one point
and it creates this effect
with the stuff and essentially i'm
following
this side a bit like i did with the ball
and chain
when i was doing the isolation
and it makes the staff feel really light
when you're moving it round
now for example we're looking at with
the sword and i take this motion where
i'm bringing it around
and get underneath the sword bring it
around now i'm following behind it
it now could turn into a downward thrust
or i could take it round to the other
side
it gives me that option so essentially
i'm creating a circle and then at any
point on that circle
you can go off on a tangent and thrust
so some of you might already be doing an
isolation without even realizing it
if we take the 15th suburi for example
this movement here
is a thrust that's actually going
off a tangent from a circle
when i was talking before about this
movement here
see as it's moving around it's actually
going off
a tangent it's this circular motion
here so it's that same circular motion
but as it comes down it's turning into a
thrust
it's moving around that circle and then
shooting off at a tangent
so once you start to understand the
isolation there's so many other things
that you can explore such as anti-spins
however i'll cover that in another video
so i hope you found that interesting if
you did leave your comments down below
and if you enjoyed the video remember to
like share and subscribe as this helps
the channel grow
anyway until next time take care and i
hope to see you soon
you